ohayo gozaimasu watashi no namae wa ba
police say she buried a building yokocho
hello everyone and good evening my name
is poopy and welcome to pool news this
is going into news Sonic didn't oopsie
YouTube oopsy doopsy
antic a pretty big oopsie but most
importantly no pretty pie oopsy this
week see if we can hit two weeks our
first story comes from Sonic Sonic the
Hedgehog everyone's favorite little
fuzzball besides me of course the teaser
finally came out the trailer I mean of
course of the new Sonic film and you
know people were nervous that Sonic
wasn't going to live up to the
expectations we didn't read yet know
what Sonic was going to look like what
would the size of his peepee be a lot of
question still unanswered their words of
course a couple fan versions that looked
very promising people had great ideas
great expectations and great hope for
Sonic this looks pretty good that looks
like my fan art alright but without
further ado we do have a live first
world reveal footage exclusive for the
first time here on pew news the trailer
roll it
[Music]
Wow that's amazing
finally they did it finally a decent
Sonic
I wasn't sure with all the fan stuff
that it was gonna live up to the
expectations but this I like this I like
this a lot and I could see what they
went through here they went with a mix
of futuristic style but still capturing
the nostalgia of the old fans thank you
Paramount Pictures for doing sonic
justice excuse me we're getting live
reports now saying that that's not the
real footage money this guy I can't
believe it let's watch why do they play
oh god what is said why does he have
human teeth why would you do that what
is thanks it's just some sort of sick
joke he says Christ that's my reaction
and why is no one talking about the fact
that here he came like dodge missiles in
real time but for some reason he can't
dodge an arrow to the freaking knee Oh
arrow to the knee I get it that's good
that's good that's a really good joke
this shot of Jim Carrey in the end made
it look cool I think I read somewhere so
it's a pretty legit source I think I
read a comment somewhere that's we only
look for the motard hitting evidence
here on Pew News saying that this is
just a post credit see very disappointed
and so was a lot of people it has
500,000 dislikes and I think people just
have had enough Jeff Fowler the director
of producer I don't know tweeted out
saying thank you for support and the
criticism the message is loud and clear
you aren't happy with the design and you
want changes it's going to happen
everyone at Paramount and say I don't
think everyone ok and Sega are fully
committed to making this character the
best he can be
hashtag sonic movie got a fix fast you
can't fix Sonic he's dead ok Sonic is
dead and we killed him
there is however one man one man who can
save us all from the suffering because
he's been carrying that suffering
yes four years
Sammy the Frick is the only one that can
save Sonic he's been trying to warn us
he tried to tell us for so long
I mean even myself I've been advocating
for fixing on saving Sonic for years I
uploaded this video two years ago stop
ruining Sonic you frickin Fricks your
fantasies can never be quenched
I wonder how tails is gonna look like oh
oh wow that's really cool you know at
least the memes is gonna be good for
this I have a feeling it's gonna be a
great meme review episode I prefer the
real sonic I said the real one I said
the real one I mean this version what
every better this mark should have been
better
hey Paramount Pictures I heard that
you're looking for a new Sonic and what
can I say
I'm your whamon I can do it next for
those of you who some reason don't know
ethica he's a streamer and I featured
him many times on my channel so guys
what I did was this is my calculator
right gonna open it and I'll chicken 1 1
3 & 4 and when I turned around
most people know I took a freeze over
the top reactions and he's become a very
popular live streamer but if you go and
ethicist twitter it's just it's a lot of
nonsense I don't I don't know what's
happening I read this wrong using Phil I
thought I think I would go on dr. Phil
that would be something anyway and take
a live stream in himself on Instagram
and someone called the police and he
live through me
[Music]
okay okay okay it's girls who went on
team stars show drama learn pretty
relevant I never heard of it I know but
what would you say to them are you
actually crazy are you having a mental
breakdown like the cops took you to the
the mental place today what happened
yeah I went I became God and I walk out
that's amazing that's amazing I think I
also delivered probably the favorite
line I've heard in a very very long time
they can do exactly what they've been
doing dreamy creamy creamy just watch
dreamy creamy creamy dreamy creamy
creamy so okay how did the all this
happen I don't know and I'm not gonna
try and force some oh it's so hard to be
a streamer and youtuber but he did lose
his youtube account because I think he's
streamed porn and then he lost his
twitch account or no the order I don't
think it's important but he lost his he
got banned from twitch because he used
to slur it's kind of odd that there's no
to give kind of attitude but it's also
pretty clear that he's going through a
public breakdown I think anyone can see
that and it seems very similar to what
we've seen before kind of like with
fouseytube last year when he did pooja
Khan and it was all about I'm doing all
these great things I don't know anything
my psychology and I don't know anything
about etiquette but this is just how I
interpret the situation but it seems to
me that it took a needs help and I think
that's clear to anyone except himself
and I know a lot of people are upset
with that decay because this is a
repeated pattern that he does apparently
and people just wanted to get help and
they know even if they support him then
that won't happen everyone is just
trying different things to get him to
actually get help but the thing is you
can only get help if
want to get help and I think it's
important that to get realizes that and
I want people to share that sentiment
with him to make sure that he actually
does and I actually respect that to get
a lot but I would respect him a lot more
if he actually did
next news Susan which has been in hot
water after a leaked footage I never
thought I would say these words a leaked
footage of Susan Wojcicki talking to
Jews world let's watch so this was taken
from the whole jumper but I don't know
exactly it's a live stream or something
like that don't care but a lot of people
interpret Susan saying we're gonna help
you we're gonna make your subscribers go
way up as in YouTube being kind of
rigged against creators Jews world
obviously he isn't a youtuber he's a
musician it costs a lot of uproar I
don't think she knew she was being
filmed a lot of people saying like Oh
smaller channels are being screwed yada
yada yada I don't really see it that way
personally I think I'm not supposed to
give him but it seems more to me like
this is CEO talk where you try and
butter someone up it's obviously good
for YouTube if an artist like juice
world is on it okay we're artists in
general it's better for the ecosystem
this kind of taught it I don't think it
means anything I don't think she's gonna
go out and do like change the system to
help Jews world I don't think that
that's not what it meant here but a lot
of people are interpreting them that way
I just think it's amazing how it Susan
gets to meet Jews world why don't I get
to meet you swirl I can't believe both
me and Susan listen to angsty teenage
emo brat
hell yeah Susan also posted her update
April 30th creator blog where she
followed up on a lot of promises saying
about supporting creator artists
and artist success she talked about
meeting with a lot of creators which
we've seen wait she met Ethan Mila I
didn't see that and she linked their
second channel I guess that makes sense
she talks about how they added the self
rating system where creators to themself
can rate the video whether its
advertising friendly or not and the
thousand channels have it right now your
boy and it works really well and I think
this changes the point that a lot of
people made with the whole ad pocalypse
where there were a few bad videos from
these really I don't even know what kind
of channels there were but the whole I'm
pocalypse an area started with ads and
white supremacist content you know how
those specific videos can affect
everyone on the platform it's just kind
of ridiculous if you think about it so
to have youtubers that upload regularly
that doesn't do any bad things that it's
100% advertiser friendly and doesn't
swear in these videos anymore and it's
just a good rural overall boy in general
and hasn't had any controversy in over a
week now and I think those people are
doesn't deserve to get lower ads okay
but that's just my opinion I think it's
a step in the right direction and I'm
glad it's happening they also say that
they improve the precision by 25 percent
she also talks about the trending tab
and they're saying that they are gonna
work on having it half creators and or
at least half will be actual creators on
the trending tab so the trending was
rigged all along I knew it no she
actually explained what I thought for a
long time which was a lot of times a
very popular video of mine will not go
on trending and it's just like why Wow
why not like but the reason why is if
all my popular videos got on trending I
would always be I'm trending and just
take over the trending tab and no one
would like that either so it's basically
measured in comparison to my other
videos if one really shoots up that
video gets trending but if my all my
videos are always doing well then
there's nothing to stand out from and I
think a lot of people have a
misconception about that they look at
the view number and they're like well
this video has this many views and this
video is solo abuse why is why is this
one not trending and then
one trending that makes no sense at all
but maybe this is channel that's always
you can't even see how low I'm pointing
right now but then they get like BAM and
then electronic trending and then I was
like I would and I think this is just as
a game theory but I think a lot of
companies obviously don't upload videos
that often and then maybe they have a
trailer for some dumb schmuck
bukka video and I will the sudden I get
some more attention so they're like Oh a
trending Oh even though it's just a
company and it's BS and like screw you
Iggy Azalea like I don't like you and
that's why
so when creators upload frequently and
actually work on YouTube and Carib I
than YouTube they don't get trending
because they don't upload videos that
shoots up so therefore it's always just
a bunch of mumbo jumbo flung bush mambo
and i think i've spoken pretty
eloquently hear about the trending tab
that is it for pew news thank you guys
for watching check out merch link in
description it's only one day left if
it's not out already I am so sorry
and sayonara my fellow students why did
I say that what you never played super
simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]